I'm gonna you've been there for 36 years
it'll be 37 in May how do you how do you
stay cuz I'm I'm married and I love my
husband truly baby there's still like
moments you're like you're driving me
nuts well and he has those plenty as
well well we just you know drive each
other nuts and don't get divorced you
know I mean the joke I always say it
says we're both very stubborn the only
way out of this is on the horizontal my
husband are very stubborn but you know I
got lucky I adore my wife I met her
first week of freshman year in college
you know and and we didn't go out right
away with which I was - - so - nervous
and geeky nomen would have gone out with
me but so we had a few years where we
we're too busy in the stairwell look
like a Dateline specials gonna happen he
was going up she was coming down the
stairs to go out with some guy and I was
going up the stairs to see a girl and we
passed not a word was spoken I remember
to this day which she had platform shoes
on bell-bottoms tight and the Glitter
belt I was going yeah and she was an
amazing amazing dancer and and she would
look so cool and I was little and I just
never I don't remember anything but I
remember that I remember the first one I
thought my husband - yes yeah I felt
like an energy crazy yeah people say
that you're like whatever until you feel
it in your life maybe there's something
to that I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this